[Music]
slavery the treatment of human beings as
property deprived of personal rights has
occurred in many forms throughout the
world but one institution stands out for
both its global scale and its lasting
legacy the Atlantic slave trade
occurring from the late 15th to the mid
19th century and spanning three
continents forcibly brought more than 10
million Africans to the Americas the
impact it would leave affected not only
these slaves and their descendants but
the economies and histories of large
parts of the world there had been
centuries of contact between Europe and
Africa via the Mediterranean but the
Atlantic slave trade began in the late
1400s with Portuguese colonies in West
Africa and Spanish settlements of the
Americas shortly after the crops grown
in the new colonies sugar cane tobacco
and cotton were labor-intensive and
there were not enough settlers or
indentured servants to cultivate all the
new land American natives were enslaved
but many died from new diseases while
others effectively resisted and so to
meet the massive demand for labor the
Europeans looked to Africa African
slavery had existed for centuries in
various forms some slaves were
indentured servants with a limited term
and the chance to buy one's freedom
others were more like European serfs in
some societies slaves could be part of a
masters family own land and even rise to
positions of power but when white
captains came offering manufactured
goods weapons and rum for slaves African
kings and Merchants had little reason to
hesitate they viewed the people they
sold not as fellow Africans but
criminals debtors or prisoners of war
from rival tribes by selling them Kings
enriched their own realms and
strengthened them against neighboring
enemies African kingdoms prospered from
the slave trade but meeting the
Europeans massive demand created intense
competition slavery replaced other
criminal sentences and capturing slaves
became a motivation for war rather than
its result to defend themselves from
slave
raids neighboring kingdoms needed
European firearms which they also bought
with slaves the slave trade had become
an arms race altering societies and
economies across the continent as for
the slaves themselves they faced
unimaginable brutality after being
marched to slave forts on the coast
shaved to prevent lice and branded they
were loaded onto ships bound for the
Americas about 20% of them would never
see land again most captains of the day
were tight packers cramming as many men
as possible below deck while the lack of
sanitation caused many to die of disease
and others were thrown overboard for
being sick or as discipline the
captain's ensured their profits by
cutting off slaves ears as proof of
purchase some captives took matters into
their own hands many inland Africans had
never seen White's before and thought
them to be cannibals constantly taking
people away and returning for more
afraid of being eaten or just to avoid
further suffering they committed suicide
or starved themselves believing that in
death their souls would return home
those who survived were completely
dehumanized treated as mere cargo women
and children were kept above deck and
abused by the crew while the men were
made to perform dances in order to keep
them exercised and curb rebellion what
happened to those Africans who reached
the new world and how the legacy of
slavery still affects their descendants
today is fairly well known but what is
not often discussed is the effect that
the Atlantic slave trade had on Africa's
future not only did the continent lose
tens of millions of its able-bodied
population but because most of the
slaves taken were men the long-term
demographic effect was even greater when
the slave trade was finally outlawed in
the Americas and Europe the African
kingdoms whose economies it had come to
dominate collapsed leaving them open to
conquest and colonization
and the increased competition and influx
of European weapons fuelled warfare and
instability that continues to this day
the Atlantic slave trade also
contributed to the development of racist
ideology most African slavery had no
deeper reason than legal punishment or
intertribal warfare but the Europeans
who preached a universal religion and
who had long ago outlawed enslaving
fellow Christians needed justification
for a practice so obviously at odds with
their ideals of equality so they claimed
that Africans were biologically inferior
and destined to be slaves making great
efforts to justify this theory
thus slavery in Europe and the Americas
acquired a racial basis making it
impossible for slaves and their future
descendants to attain equal status in
society in all of these ways the
Atlantic slave trade was an injustice on
a massive scale whose impact has
continued long after its abolition
you
[Music]